for more time your next comic coming up
is also from out of town so give a big
warm welcome news from Austin sister
city Seattle so hey yeah get that going
in is Hans kid it's good to be here I'm
also from out of town for the West Coast
we're slowly infiltrating Austin because
we know the war is coming when once you
on our side come join us
what do you say this up the girl that's
been telling it the whole time it's cool
you know this is Texas you can do what
you want I think of what I want to and
talking about you I'm using your weapon
against you you're talking I'm talking
we're all talking they say in Texas is
the Lone Star State is the same as the
Lone Star State the whole galaxy is a
Lone Star galaxy you might like us
you're not special
we're all alone starring it I'm just as
lonely as you are
Austin it's like a sunny Seattle it's
like hipsters that don't want to kill
themselves so they can work on heroin
and killing ourselves you guys are like
the weather it's too good I'm gonna tan
I am NOT conservative I'm a liberal
because I think conservatives are wrong
that's fine
well someone's gotta be wrong who do you
think it is okay we can't both be right
who do you think's wrong the the
plumbers are the political scientists
put things right about politics
conservators are great and things just
on politics are great at fishing stick
to your specialty we'll stick to ours we
don't come in there and teach you how to
hunt all right you know who should have
a peek at the nuclear codes of people
with low IQs and a fascination with
Bronze Age mythology they should be in
charge no that's not the right hobby
don't use that hobby to send off nukes I
don't know people from the future aren't
gonna come in a time machine and be like
hey you keep polluting the oceans just
let the gays marry that leave [ __ ] up
space travel yeah the [ __ ] dude do you
see Jupiter you can't do both I don't
think that's gonna happen the people
with low IQs have a have a political
belief that benefits large corporations
I wonder what happened there maybe they
got tricked there's no way this is a
normal conversation you're doing this on
purpose you're like I'm gonna be drunk
and ruin people trying to do something
anyone can ruin things it's hard to
create you're not special come on dude
come on Arnie that's it humor what you
said I am so rich that it's easy to be
poor
I feel him the best way to be poor is if
you're rich because then you can buy a
book
culture people say that you can't make
funny jokes about white people and race
you can't make funny white race jokes
like you can't do it as well as you can
with the Asians or black people but you
can and it's really effective because
they get really sensitive I vote against
their own interests like they did in the
last election thank you pretty brave
saying I shouldn't Austin Texas sister
city yeah well how do you guys all right
how are you guys alive here if there was
a Seattle in Texas I would not think
that it would be alive I think they
invade you and shoot you in the face
some people some women clutch the purses
when they're around black people the
same way that I clutched my retirement
plan whenever I'm around a white person
get your Bernie Madoff hands off my
retirement plan [ __ ] trying to
enter on me so I can flip me out Texas
experience completed I feel like I feel
like college is like a peacock with its
feathers like if you see a peacock with
large feathers you're like oh it [ __ ] it
survived in the wild with that large
feather and let me [ __ ] it like if
you're in college some ladies I know you
studied communication with four years of
your life you must done really good let
me [ __ ] you communications patron please
someone [ __ ] me
that's what I think I so much [ __ ]
hello everybody
what if her name went for Nate's with
Eileen and she's like I'm gonna stop
talking they're gonna come on